We often call an encryption
scheme a cipher.
You may not have realized this,
but encryption has been used for
thousands of years.
For example,
there is an evidence that Ancient
Egyptians used some sort of ciphers.
And then there is
the famous Caesar's cipher,
as well as other similar schemes.
There are several types of ciphers.
Symmetric ciphers, range from ancient
schemes to present day algorithms.
Asymmetric ciphers are relatively new,
only invented in the late 70s.
Most security protocols now
use both types of schemes.
Typically, they first
use asymmetric ciphers
to authenticate both parties
involved in the communication.
And then establish and exchange
a encryption key for the communication.
Then they use symmetric ciphers, and
the established encryption key
to encrypt data and traffic.
They can also use asymmetric ciphers
to digitally sign the data, so
that they can ensure data authenticity.